[Music]
hello guys today's lecture
uh on the end games in saying the end
game
um so today i wanna didn't i didn't
prepare anything
like a particular topic uh
a part like temp chest-wise i'm prepared
basically two games of magnus carson
from 2020
were which i think were very interesting
from for a number of reasons uh
mostly from practical point of view and
kind of like practical
perspective from practical chess
i mean sometimes in equal end games
it is very easy to um
not know when you go wrong and i think
uh especially in the first one
the one what i want to talk about
against ali
zafiruja it was pretty clear
that you know in equal one game alireza
simply misplayed it
and then gave magnus huge chances
but before i started start talking too
much let's just get into the game
so the first position i wanted to talk
about is the following one
right after the opening position is just
equal actually i
should flip the board because we're
mostly interested from black's
perspective
um positions just right
completely equal like there are no any
problems near for white nor for black
and i think that in general
no in with good play the game should end
with a draw
so uh here i'll erase a plate natural
naturally rookie movie fd1 is a good
move obviously
i personally i feel like a little more
accurate could have been maybe rook c8
but both moves were equally good
so we don't i mean it doesn't quite
matter let's say after rook c8
i would consider maybe like i don't know
king g7
maybe just root b8 attack this pawn
bring another rook there
probably at some point the groups will
trade let's say h5 h4 knight c6
finally trade nothing really happens
it's one of the possible scenarios
which can happen there and of course
position just totally equal
no really any chances for any of the
sides uh
however in this position uh okay rook
fd1 uh
followed which is which is also okay
king g7 also normal move
but right now iris i played with knight
e3 uh which i'm not entirely sure
whether it's a
is the best move and honestly it seems
to me like it's a first step a little
bit in the wrong direction direction
uh first of all knight on d5 is
perfectly located like there is no
better square for this knight than on d5
and i don't see a reason why to move
this knight from there uh
so maybe there was idea of knight c4 or
something like this i understand that
but like y to move design from d5 still
like
it's still the best square for this
knight there uh
why should let's say try to focus on
improving the bishop from f3
so and uh especially considering that
c files fully control there is
possibility to play your
moves like rook c8 again or maybe rook
c5 to put some pressure on e5 pawn
for instance after uh rook c5 of idea
i don't know maybe not an id3 attack
spawn only five at this
rook a6 a3 uh yeah like
i think blackboard has pretty good
position
as unless something like this this and
knight xc6 is just equal beat xc6
trying to kill the knight from uh d5
also is possible but then
e3 just knight c4 comes and definitely
no any problems for white neither for
black positions is still equal
so uh yeah this was one of the ways to
play here for alireza however he'll move
that e3 which
is still not not really a bad move but
like it's i think the first step in the
wrong direction
uh rook a6 a
very strong move the idea is right now
to
take seize the initiative pretty much
and start attacking pawns on the queen
side
a3 and h5 and right now again
uh there is some problem
right now uh for uh for white because
right now could be a bishop move like
rook f6 could be a fret
uh i'll just draw an arrow here roger
six could be a threat
bishop on the f3 is under some pressure
right now
uh if we can bring this rook to f6 so
[Music]
how to solve this problem the most
natural move again
seems like knight c4 following the plan
like right 1993 and now knight 94 makes
sense
um it's possible i'm not saying it's a
big is a mistake or something is but
like it's
a little bit imprecise like all the
moves
are slightly slightly inaccurate and
this eventually
may build up to something really big and
it did in the end
uh so we will see so uh i would play
or at least consider i know what i would
play in the game but i don't ask you
rook d3 and i think it made his move
makes a lot of sense because uh right
now
as i said the main point that what has
to be done
in this position which open f3 is a
problem like if this bishop would be
let's say
somehow on c4 would be a great bishop
right but on the freight
it's pretty bad like it doesn't do
anything and runs into some
some attacks so therefore rook d3
makes perfect sense because we want to
play bishop d1 for instance and we
should be free
one of the ideas and another idea is
simply to
over protect bishop on a free on the
third rank after
f6 we can play if we don't want to play
in [ __ ] knight bishop d1 we can play
knight d5 for instance even but bishop
d1 is also totally okay
but after both positions just are just
equal and
if h4 on the other hand uh we can begin
counter attacking rook c5
and now that c4 would make more sense
but yeah this this would probably
be the correct player by white and still
position is just equal
let's say neuro g8 knight c4 takes takes
pawn e5 is hanging
if i was hanging so uh b5 trying to
at least go for bishop f6 right now but
again
right now in this in this endgame there
is no
any reason for why to be worried uh
actually
white has extra pawns so probably black
has to be
slightly curved you know slightly more
careful but obviously just to draw
because of the opposite color bishops
and the likelihood of
trading all the pawns on the queen side
and simply
withdrawn endgame so
so yeah like here knight c4 again is
slight inaccuracy i would say it's not
the
not anything serious still position is
just still roughly equal
but like it gives some possibilities for
black to develop some initiative and
magnus
did i think great a great way bishop f6
defining this pawn simply and uh
right now h4 also makes sense seemingly
but again the best move
according to what i analyze knight e3
back
so if you have gold knight c4 knight d3
all those moves are not really
natural really right because you won't
want to play
let's see four to attack on the bishop
sorry paul on e5
so knights four seemingly placed well
afterwards was the plan but
suddenly it feels like the best move is
starting to move back 93 which is all
not lodging
kind of like natural so uh
i feel like aleris i was struggling to
find the correct plan and he could have
been
i mean he actually indeed was in the end
punished for us because he lost
uh but yeah like normally what do i
should do just
you know focus on improving pieces
bishop on the front f3 has to be
improved
like here a move rook d3 would make a
lot of sense and bring this bishop to
the game which would be one we should be
free i'll just draw again
uh i mean i'll draw the arrow here this
one could be one of the ideas
so uh but knight c4 also is okay just
need to go back night in
id3 probably because after h4 black can
uh bring bring the rook to the game rook
93 and rook 86 and suddenly black made
some progress magnus made some progress
here because
right now he controls the c file so it
is definitely some progress
we cannot say that you know position is
still totally equal
we have to acknowledge that black
controls the c file right now
and black knight on d4 actually still is
on d4 and
causes some you know problems to white
while
uh white from knight from has to be
right now on e3 because
otherwise rook will invade rook c2
so uh it suddenly is not entirely easy
so are you gonna play bishop d3 s3 rook
d3 and now magnus brings this uh
bishop to the game bishop d8 bishop d1
finally brewing this bishop rook c1
and again position is still
around equal like it position was so dry
so he called it even after several
inaccuracies
uh from white it's still around equal
but uh
right now but like with each you know
inaccuracy is the white starts getting
harder and harder let's say on practical
level
and right now i recently should be free
and i don't
i think it was again maybe
not the most precise way to play i would
i would consider a4 as the best move
with idea of gaining some space on the
king side a queen side and then
trying to play maybe should be free
bishop d5 because if b should be fair b
should be free immediately
now b5 a very strong move by magnus and
the
it's black who came who has control over
the
uh some important squares on the
queensland let's say c4
or uh you know simply just advancing and
gaining space
so yeah that's why
you know it's slowly slowly getting more
and more unpleasant
for for white rook d1 makes sense right
now
obviously we cannot trade rooks we have
to keep as many pieces on the board as
possible
however i wanted to point out what
happens after knight xb3 because this
seems interesting because what could be
wrong with just winning the spawn
somehow right
taking on b2 next and you know after
rook d5 simply a6
giving e5 by winning b two pawn and
trying to you know win every pawn and
then start pushing those two bombs
forward let's say
after uh rook takes e5 root xb2 would be
simply great
like rook a2 and uh maybe knight c1 id3
ids as well all
this looks just great for black i think
that would be just winning here
however there is i want to point out
that
in here it will be white black stars
wouldn't be so trivial after move like
g4 which activates the knight from ev3
which is essential after h6 g4 knight
takes
and white takes the knight on e5
preparing rook d7
and after rook a2 we can play as wide
network d7 looking for counter play
so try basically why it holds by
active thanks to active counter play
like this
so therefore this knight xb3 move
doesn't quite work
but you know no need to even calculate
this rook c8 maintains
the pressure so from practical point of
view um
just you know this is this is the best
move uh bishop a2
and now simply a5 still weak our black
is controlling the a file
uh i don't know only four is a little
bit better than knight
from on e3 and uh if black managed to
manage to play a4
there would be also fixed maybe
potentially some weaknesses on the on a
queen side
so rook d3 happened a4
and right now
probably i mean we can see clearly that
this position is already
getting more and more dangerous for
white like it's becoming
white black is clearly making some
progress right and especially against
magnus who is
you know who has such a great technique
uh it is definitely not the the most
pleasant uh position to play
against so uh i think that
it was time it was it was a good time
basically to
[Music]
bring this rook back actually and just
try to play passive
passive defense because you know roxy
one could could be always some idea but
only one covers it so i'm not sure
whether this would be free actually was
really used
really useful but just bring the print
group there
and maybe right now bring play knight to
b5 95 knight b4 if you can
let's have a bishop b6 and i before
something like this could be possible
um or i don't know
just stay in place just try not to make
any blunder and hope to save the game
because because also it's not easy to
make progress with black for instance if
black ever tries to explain the queen
sorry king side of g5
let's say g5 white can consider maybe
even taking
taking and knight f5 and the trade this
trade could be
simply you know further simplifying the
position even though roxy ii
could be you know a possibility
d7 could be a counter to this so idea of
rook d7 is definitely one of the
you know things that white black white
uh sorry black has to watch out for
so for instance roxy turtle g7 would be
some unclear end game probably drawn
objectively
but uh is anyway i'm doing what i'm
trying to say it's not so easy to make
progress with black so after rook d1
i don't know what black would do maybe
black can you know make some king of
eight king jake g7
triangulation for no specific reason
because then white also can play king of
one king g2 just wait
so uh probably white can still hold it
and probably white should normally hold
is you know quite
didn't do any huge blunders maybe some
small inaccuracies which makes
over the board from practical level
position more and more unpleasant but
still it is it is okay
so uh it was possible possibly it was
the
path to go so right now uh i rather
played king
f1 which i don't see you really see
where this king is going
i already see where this king is going
just bishop b6
and uh finally right now aliroza played
rook c3
which is again i think a little bit not
the
not in the correct you know not in the
not correct move not the right direction
probably just bishop d5 trying to
improve this bishop was correct however
uh still you know
black is slightly slightly better
they're even if anyone can win this it
will only it will be black
right now but yeah like possibly we
should d5 with idea
let's say to keep to keep this
as a there is a defensive resource a or
in knight c2 just go for rogue free and
contemplate on f7
so this probably was better try to
defend
still black can play simply move f6 or
maybe prepare f5 at some point
black is slightly better and no question
about that
however i really think that
you know with correct play white should
sort of hold it
because rook c3 is suddenly is lead to
huge problems
and to be honest as i analyzed this
i still didn't find like clear
kind of clean wave to win this with
black i saw huge chances of course but
like everywhere
with best sometimes extremely difficult
moves
uh white can hold up but okay let's see
take stakes knight b3
king e1 bringing the king to the center
knight d2
was the fret now we shot c5 and knight
c2
so uh this in this so this is the
critical position essentially of this
end game
and in in here i believe that um
magnus made a mistake which uh
sort of like i don't know
how to put it but i think the mistake i
don't know what was called maybe was
time travel because move number 36
but this mistake causes uh white to be
back in the back in the game
pretty much like right now black has a
huge advantage
first of all pawn structure a knight
on i mean knight to
b3 is very strong you can black can
never take it
with the bishop from v3 because then
possible will be just deciding
and also knight
on on before the restricts that bishop
from a2
in general in such positions the good
strategy for you know attacking side
is to create second weakness because
right now there's only one we can spawn
on the
pawn on a3 and it would be good to
create some weakness on the king's
try to do this however you know with
correct play
i i couldn't find the way to break
through hero as
black so i analyzed several
possibilities one of the
main ones that i consider as you know
one the most interesting was let's say
f5 this seems like the most natural
play move to play you just open you know
fight for the center try to maybe
potentially create some potential
weaknesses
uh but knight before i know and i for
the f takes e4 would be
correct and bishop b1 and uh
there are basically two moves for uh for
black one move the most natural move at
least to me would be
to play e3 and second move a little bit
more difficult
but still quite logical is knight a5 and
knight c4 attack this a3 pawn
so let's see what happens after both if
e3 takes takes
knight d5 suddenly we do not have a good
way
with our bishop to cover
c7 square and the knight seven happens
next
or simply bishop d3 we can we don't have
time to sort of protect our pawn on b5
and
so and also upon a4 therefore and we are
losing them
so let's say bishop c1 trying to at
least take this a3 pawn
but now bishop d3 takes takes knight c5
and
knight b6 and this end game very likely
will end
with with a draw because pawn only 4
falls after 94
bishop takes a4 tactically still it
still sort of holds for white because
after knight hg3 there is knight c4
possibility
so uh okay now knight c4
and suddenly you know position
simplifies significantly and the
very likely game the game would end with
a draw
still there are some chances for black
there's bishop e7 possibility but like
uh very likely we just
draw uh alternative would be let's say
we should be two at first but then
we are not taking c pawn uh we are
winning still upon but suddenly pawn on
c5 is just going forward and
we have to give back a piece for this uh
for respawn
for instance after this king f1 a bishop
a5 and knight d5 we cannot stop this
c pawn c6 and the game is pretty much
wrong because uh you know we have to
give the piece and then
you know none of the sides
actually can win so it's just just a
draw
uh i'll just put the arrow just to show
yeah so seven just
next and it should be simply a draw
because if 96 then it should be seven
always so
uh there is no way to win this
so coming back this is what happens
after in here
e3 right this will just discuss e3
however there's al the alternative we
just move knight a5
and i define i just bring knight c4 and
knight takes a3 to win this pawn
and it's also very interesting but again
after bishop before knight c4 uh knight
bishop c6 knight xa3 knight d3
and here let's say bishop d6 makes a lot
of sense to just do the defender's e5
pawn
king d1 i even though black has extra
pawn
it is hard to kind of like come up with
what to do next
because uh even okay if not king the one
will be knight b one at least this
is clear right but if king d1 knight b1
will always be king c2
if we ever touch this you know knight
from uh a3 let's say
the pawn before we will fall so we
cannot do that
and uh with such bishop on c6
we can never really you know get this
night out so probably we have to give
back the pawn
but then knight c4 uh bishop c6 back and
if a free knight c1 and let's say bishop
c5 analyzed
king 296 some force line but bishop d5
and in such endgame even though black
has clear advantage still
i am not entirely sure whether this is
objectively winner because pawn on a3 is
blocked
and with such pawn structure on the
queen king side
i'm not sure whether there is a
possibility to
you know bring our king to the um
to the you know uh to the center and
then to the queen side
because pawns on g6 and h5 will simply
fall and therefore i think
despite the advantage for black
objectively one has really good chances
to save this
so like at least i couldn't ionize this
a little bit deeper but like i
in order to not to overwhelm
you guys with the analysis and so on i
think it's
this person is already pretty clear that
there is it's not easy to
for black to make progress
so in this position another possibility
uh after apart from f5 i analyze move f6
and the idea of f6 is to prepare g5
create possible somehow or maybe some
weaknesses at least on the king side in
this way
essentially as i said we have to play on
the king side uh
to create second weekends and this was
also very interesting
and i analyzed number of possibilities
here
uh for uh white uh yeah
yeah for white so basically i think
there are two of them
f3 and i before uh after
f3 g g5 i think there could be
okay still it's pretty you know
you know at least we've got this pawn on
h4 like it still is pretty
uh hard to win this but at least this
pawn h4 could be potentially some sort
of
or weakness bishop e7 maybe f5 then
still
not easy far from easy but at least
maybe some chances
uh however i think that knight before
immediately
is also pretty good uh knight
a5 a free knight c4 it would be an idea
and go for his end game and the question
is whether this is
you know how how big of chances does
black have in this end game
and again probably with correct play is
a draw
but it doesn't matter what i'm trying to
say all those
on all those lines with best play
probably
white can hold but you know starting
from
number 20 or whatever it was when it was
just totally equal
to get there suddenly it psychologically
it's very very difficult to defend such
positions because of what you had
and right now you know
why black has pretty much risk-free
position
so knight d5 let's say and uh i know
analysis f5 king d2 and f4
trying to sort of you know create some
imbalance on the king side
after gtx4 it takes f4 uh
king d1 was suddenly the best defense
which is of course very difficult to
find and basically just
start trying to stay in place because if
for instance 94
this would be already lost because
bishop takes a3
and we black doesn't have move knight b6
which
normally would have to be you know uh
played to attack those pawns
and therefore kingdom wants them has to
be played to
have after bishop blake's a3 knight b6
always
so yeah like for instance this knight g2
i feel like you know we have to defend
spawn h for somehow but right now
simply bishop comes to uh
you know slowly to d6 then kim
we bring our king and finally bring this
bishop to f6
and black wins with a free uh idea at
some point because
our troops [ __ ] because seemingly it
seems like there is no breakthrough but
suddenly uh also
there is no way don't move for black
because for white because if e5
bishop bison king goes
then king simply goes you know there
and the game is over and if the king
goes to c2 then pawn goes forward as
well and
it's essentially next to funk the game
is just over
so that's why you cannot take this
knight
with the knight the pawn on f4 and you
have to stay in play with king d1
but you know such moves are very
difficult uh
so you know if you have to
if you have to find defining such moves
it means and
previous positions were much easier it
means definitely something went wrong on
the
on the way so king f7 uh bishop f2
here some crazy lines happen it doesn't
quite matter because
you know now knight b6 and trying to you
know simplify the position and
eventually after we should be seven
knight c4 uh bishop f6
sorry not sorry g5 g5 g5 was better try
and as also bishop f6 but if i have a
better try
trying to play simply g4 and you know to
create a park here creating
some strong pawn chain but right now
simply king of one was very
important move to for white to play and
suddenly white can hold because king
comes to g2
and we eliminate pawn on a4 as well and
then bring the knight so even though
and probably white will be down upon but
uh
maybe even duponts but
you know there will be some pretty no
pretty uh solid
defense with the king on g2 and those
pawns gonna go forward
after bishop f6 knight b6 a certain
and then e5 has first to be played
because if knight b6
which was c3 knight a4 and now if very
important move bishop d4
and this knight on the a4 is dominated
it can
basically right now black essentially
win but
white can play something better than
that instead of knight knight b6 there's
possibility to start with e5 at first
after bishop b7 now knight b6 and as i
said like
very likely white will be down upon but
this knight is coming to safety and
here you know it's just this is just
obviously a draw of course all the moves
were
probably the best or one of the best for
both sides
and with the correct play the game
should end the draw but
how many crazy moves had to be found
over there like for instance this
idea of king d1 uh at first just
a waiting move like this is there none
of this is easy
to figure out during the game during
analysis of course or
you know with when you're sitting at
your desk with with engine
and so on it's very easy to find such
moves like it's obvious
but when you have to play you have to
figure out why not knight takes the f4
which captures the pawn right
so definitely something went really
wrong and this move rook c3 allowed all
sort of like here
in here this move works if you allowed
all sort of chances like this for magnus
and this was a huge this was a huge
mistake here by
ireland even though probably it was
still not
causing a lost position so after
this this night b3 but not bishop c5
knight c2 and but right now magnus play
move knight c1 instead
and the knight c1 actually throws away
all the chances
uh right now you just simply draw like
probably
magnus played under some time pressure
or something because
otherwise i don't think he'll ever make
such a mistake
because uh bishop d5 suddenly this
bishop is back to the game
better try would be let's say as i said
f5 or f6 or maybe just make some waiting
move like king f6 or something like this
uh but yeah knight c1 just
gives it all away like bishop d5 uh
knight d3 and
yes you're winning the pawn but suddenly
bishop c6 and
this bishop which was horrible in the
previous previous lines
right now it's coming to the game and
the attack simply will spawn on a b5 and
a4
and the game is pretty much just drawn
right now with correct play so next
let's say 20 moves both players play
perfect chess so i would just you know
go over you know how they played because
you know i have nothing pretty much to
add
like f6 93 knight h1 attacking spawn
knight on uh
with the knight upon on g3 we should
take the a3
take takes bishop b2 and extra pawn for
for magnus but right now knight on h1 is
a
it's you know is a bad piece so king f3
he has to spend time for bishop d4
trying to you know get his knight out to
the game and if he was only on time to
play main f2 and then knight g4
probably he still have some decent
chances uh
in this end game but simply g4
simplifies the position and the game is
i think immediately drawn should be at
least after takes takes
knight f2 knocking f3 still some chances
practical chances obviously but
uh it's simply two loom of material
right now
and opposite corrections also give
additional drawing chances
knight g3 the king is not coming to h5
knight d3
bishop e8 and knight f4 pretty good
defense
bishop f7 knight c5 just staying in
place h5
is one of the ideas obviously and here
ali raza goes for it
great defense by euros so far we should
take bishop
now of course taking on h5 would
uh like simplify the position further we
can take the knight or with the bishop
probably then it's easier
it's just just draw after
but magnus tribe should be one trying to
at least
trade uh the knight uh
and the for the bishop and play position
with
knight versus with black knight versus
white bishop
uh name name namely something like this
and such engage are always very
interesting because the question is
whether the knight can jump around
and capture the h5 pawn in such way that
it will be uh
winning for uh or like you know that you
know why would not be able to transport
to pawn end game
and the the answer for that is that this
is not simply possible
because for king of three knight b3
that's how it happened in the game
just king g3 and if only you know let's
say bishop e8 happened
and i take the h5 right now white
wouldn't be able to take because
the black weighs due to the opposition
like in g3 uh king g5 and you know the
king
just goes forward the game is over right
uh however
obviously ali raza played with king g3
here and after takes
uh it is possible to take already it's
also
as i know it's possible to play this but
it's simply unnecessary
because it gives additional practical
chances for for black to you know just
jump around
there is some room for error right now
for for white
no no sense to play this i think
especially if bishop takes h5
king plays h5 king h3 is fear there's
just theoretical drop
by the opposition and this standard
position so i was surprised that alireza
lost it
but yeah okay king some happens to
anyone i guess
so king h6 king h4 king g7 kg3
right now the idea is simply to keep the
hold i mean to hold the
distant position and
the game is just over so i will explain
what happened
in let's say from what i in my opinion
let's say this happened king of two king
seven king e2
uh all right king e8 i'll probably king
e3
king e1 will be probably the most
precise just just to keep this
opposition
just in any case uh
but okay king e2 also also works after
king e6 king e3
king d7 king d3 yeah king d6
and of course right now white has to
play move king d2
and this is uh immediately opposition
right i'm back to back to opposition
king c5 king c3 there is no breakthrough
available
it's just it's just draw like it's just
uh correspond like white has all the
corresponding squares
to black king and
just just draw it's just it's just due
to the standard position
what i think that happened here is that
probably alireza wanted to play king c4
or something
and then kind of like forgot about
and then realized more like that that
king c4 doesn't work
it's kind of like my to my understanding
because
he realized after king is six king goes
from this side
and suddenly white is not in time to
play sorry king h5 obviously
and right now it as we get to the
position as we discussed earlier and
the game is over due to the black having
the opposition
over the white king and uh maybe this is
what he
noticed and that's why he panicked sort
of and that's why he played king c3
but of course king c3 loses due to king
c5 and right now black has opposition
and
others simply resigned so i don't know
how to
prob either my explanation is correct or
not or my assumption
but sort of makes sense to me that this
happened because otherwise how how can
you not play candy too
it's uh i mean it's just very natural
it's just on the position right so uh
king c5 king c3 as we just draw so
anyway uh this is this game
uh i think very interesting uh from
practical perspective how magnus was
applying more brush more and more
pressure on equal position
uh and from move on to move
it was getting harder and harder for
alireza to defend and finally no
more mistakes followed um
[Music]
in the end rook c3 move was giving huge
chances to manage which magnus didn't
capitalize on immediately
and he played with 36 knight c1 which
was
inaccurate obviously however anyway
it was uh ireza was still under pressure
and sometimes
you know when you are entire game you
know defending and defending
there is a chance there is increased
chance at least of making a mistake
because
of the you know
because being it's not it's not easy to
place on to play under pressure
and be defending so uh this would be it
for this game another game that i
prepared
was uh i mean is another game of magnus
uh so give me a second
all right so this is the position i want
to talk about
this is um game hare krishna
versus um carlson from sasebo masters
2020 and
in in this position
let's evaluate first who is like
what's going on so i think in my opinion
in my opinion i think that position is
just around equal
it should be pretty much like white has
no
no really any weaknesses the material is
balanced equal
or black beads maybe are slightly more
active because of design only six
potentially going to d4 if knight bishop
breaks freak happens
uh also this bishop on this long
diagonal is very strong quinoa
it is you know going maybe to a1
sometimes
it's you know there are some chances
maybe practical chances for black
however it is not not
clear why black would would be better
like objectively because white doesn't
have any weaknesses
material is equal and if like few more
simplifications happen the game will
just end with a draw
so the right now the simplest uh
move for white right now i would be
probably in my opinion to play move b4
and with idea to play c5 just you know
to play c5 uh and trade more pawns
and there is there are certain
possibilities for both sides right now
uh i think yeah this should be just just
this reason and with a draw let's say if
f6
it makes sense to play project pawn e5
over protect
because c5 may be a an idea for white
but then just b5
if queen a1 is simply queen b6 right now
black king is simply a little bit weak
and the queen you know will always find
some perpetual for instance
bishop b4 queen d6 94 if not for a
perpetual black would be winning but of
course queen 7 is just just a draw
because there is no way to escape from
from checks so
f6 is not really a problem here and if
queen a1
then queen b6 again is you know counter
idea for for white and
i don't think white will have any
problems here to you know get a good
game
knight d4 queen takes b7 knight takes e2
or logical
and simply king g2 making sure the king
is safe
i don't see any problems here for for a
while whatsoever position just
just okay so
possibly white may try to play b5 b6 at
some point
yeah one important thing to know though
uh queen b5 would be maybe a little bit
inaccurate due to queen f1 ideas
sometimes
that's why king just want to play at
first and then push b5 maybe b6 at some
point
and just uh hope that you know those
pawns
will be you know at least good
destruction from black's initiative on
white's king
but in general there should be any
problems for uh for black
so i mean for white uh yeah so in this
position
before as i said was the simplest
however
hare krishna played with c5 and this
move uh leads to i i think at least
what uh i wanted to achieve
that um he wanted to trade some pawns
trade some pawns tactically and simplify
the position
because you know he makes sense because
knight panda king on h2 could be
sometimes you know
uh under some pressure and you know if
let's say net x
e5 take the knight x finite x e5
you know if d takes e5 queen takes c5
this is totally okay for white and or
actually what could be better because of
the past pawn
and if not uh not this then you know
we can play neither frequent if sorry
bring knight back play queen d4
and have you know great chances to
you know maybe win the game as white and
because of the outside b pawn that we
have and potentially
black king could be a rather weak than
than white king however there is a small
tactical problem right now with queen a1
so queen a1 proverb i guess i don't know
i cannot say for sure
this is what pantala harry krishna
missed because
queen h1 is a big threat right now and
also
if white defense we can simply take
capture
on b2
important thing to note small detail if
bishop takes f3 would be
imprecise because queen d4 or queen c3
and then we capture
so uh therefore taking so therefore
white would be able to hold
material balance and therefore black
simply has to take
and this is a critical position another
critical position
what to do here with white white simply
lost the pawn right
definitely it wasn't you didn't go as
planned but
um what to do next and here i think uh
white made again mistake because knight
g5
happened enough to move knight g5
i don't really know where this knight is
really going like
okay he wants to maybe queen seven or
something but like i can play for
instant bishop d5
just pretend protect everything and i
have just
extra pawn and you know i'm not sure
what design on g5 is doing
not sure i'm not sure whether you know
it's such a great idea
however i analyzed here queen d4 that we
we have to assess at first what happens
after queen trade takes takes
so what's going on here
is it possible that white can simply
trade queens and hold this such endgame
to be honest i think this is
this is very possible this is
probably with correct play while i can
defend this and by correctly i mean
actually pretty simple play it doesn't
i don't think that it requires any thing
uh kind of like
extraordinary to hold it because of the
nature of the position
white plays f4 again those pawns like
seem in
a similar what one of the lines that i
discussed in the previous game between
alireza and magnus uh
sorry those pawns are will be object of
of attack for
for this bishop always some us some
counterparts so this king will not be
able to let's say go anywhere
because both spawns will be always under
some pressure
also with pawn on h5 white has
possibilities
i should take this one out uh with this
pawn on h5
white has possibilities of playing g4
and challenging it
and the simplifying position even
further sometimes
so i think objectively should be sort of
a
fortress or uh sometimes you know
because due to simplifications just the
game should end with a draw somehow
and i'll analyze like several
possibilities for
for for both sides of 96. makes sense to
trade the knights
but you can trade and simply g4 and uh
you know
simplifications occur
one extra point i think it's simply not
sufficient here to win with black
especially at this king if only this
king comes here
and blocks this pawn i don't think
there is a way to make any progress
so yeah things would be just uh draw
after 96
if black would try to maybe play bishop
a6
try of course black should try to
detroit bishops
if bishops would be traded it'd be much
easier to convert this
uh but of course why do not want to
trade bishops
after bishop c4 we can just bring the
king
or maybe play g4 both look both possible
to be honest uh
yeah like both moves are possible and
not sure which one is even
better both are leading to equal
engagement even like something like this
with you know bishop versus knight
because of the nature of all spawns
again on the queen side
while we get to play g4 at some point
and they are simplifications will occur
and would not be easy to convert that
any further
so with correct play white should hold
it also g4 will be
impossible immediately and this end game
also
should be drawn with correct play
because
we again do not trade the bishops the
king will stop the d4 pawn
if bishop f5 let's say this king goes
king is blocking and we again look for
counter play on this f7 pawn and g6 pawn
trying to ideally play bishop between h5
simplify even further
so i don't see any breakthrough here for
uh for white necessary for black
therefore i think queen d4
here would be a pretty much
for trans transpo transferring to uh
equal slight okay slightly better for
black but objectively
fairly easy fairly easily defundable
endgame
um knight g5 however happened energy
five
bishop is it was a mistake bishop d5
good move
over protecting on f7 making sure
everything's defended
we should be free take stakes queen f6
all good
queen e396 and knight f3
so this is next push i want to discuss
in detail
black has extra pawn obviously
great winning chances there is you know
just an extra pound and
seemingly like endless possibilities to
you know to make progress
but you know because there are so many
of them how to
make try to make progress and this is
where the tricky part
are the tricky part starts um
in this position it would be pretty much
sure to play with d5
in my opinion even though it seems like
natural you know we have extra point try
to push it forward
it will be simply premature king g2
let's say
and if let's say d4 we just go queen e4
and the
spawn doesn't really go anywhere it
doesn't go anywhere and
it's actually objective of the attack
right now uh by white pieces
black has to you know be careful not to
lose this pawn
if queen d8 then let's say queen e5
moves are possible
or even night night after queen date
night e5 trying to block it and look for
counter play
it is not easy to make uh also progress
here with with black so d5
would weaken the pawn and would sort of
put too much too much of emphasis to
on pushing the pawn instead of improving
the pieces
so i really like what magnus played here
and shows like
his great technique here and class
what what magnus does right the search
position at first
centralizes the queen centralizing the
queen is the first step
improving the queen to the center by
playing queen f5
and idea is after king g2 play queen d5
because i mean hard to better come over
than king g2 it seems pretty natural
you know improve the king for white as
well and queen d5
the queen and the queen gets to d5 and
whereas
you know that is a perfect square
and creates bunch of possibilities you
know to maybe trade queens because
ideally as black we would like to trade
queens
and the queen because if the queens are
traded it will be easier to maybe push
the pawn
uh the d-pawn somehow forward also
we could we can then improve our king
because right now with the key knights
and queens on the board it will be
pretty much impossible to improve the
king too far away because there'll be
always some checks and the counter play
so therefore black would should try to
trade queen somehow
so king g1 is logical and now king f6
slowly improving the
pieces queen c3 and the king e7 slowly
you know making some progress
queen free back okay so we the first
let's say step achieve was uh you know
achieved uh right now you know queen is
improved king is
also safer on e7 that he was on g7
doesn't go into
almost any checks only from my seven but
they are like we can deal with them by
playing one for example what carson
played doesn't have his next move
in general as the next step we should
again try to somehow trade queens
and by by uh what i mean by trading
queens
is not only try to trade queens by
themselves
by themselves because it'll be great but
like cause
white to um if not
with why decide not to trade queens
there will be some let's say
uh problem with you know giving up some
squares or
like you know there will be some other
issues what we'll be facing so let's see
what hap what how
magnus did it if we play queen c5
of course why cannot trade the queen's
queen d3 looks logical
and right now queen c1 again pretty
logical move
king g2 and move quicker now now move
queen c6
uh king g1 also is logical and again
knight c5 so what magnus does is
essentially he tries to
further improve his queen centralize
even further to e4
queen e3 queen e4 further centralization
right now of course if the queens are
traded will be to
black's great advantage there because
you know as i said earlier the d-pawn
will be easier to push also black king
will be easier to improve
and also right now white faces
serious let's say practical problem
because okay we're
to go with the queen if we do not trade
queens
where do we go of the queen because you
know if queen g5 simply f6
and we are either losing the knight or
you know trading the queens after all
so queen g5 isn't possible so
essentially are two moves they're queen
c3 or queen a3
and which one is correct is pretty much
a coin flips this decision right now
because
um it's really difficult to assess which
one is
better than the other during the game
once you analyze
or like you have great calculation you
know you could could be
or was it yeah once you analyze it would
be definitely clear
and it was what i'm gonna show right now
which why one
one is better than the other but
the reader board to figure it out during
the game at the board it's difficult to
figure it out in my opinion
because of the various factors that
affecting decision making first of all
uh
you know just i know i don't want the
time pressure on this
in this moment but i was rapid chess so
i guess there was
you know the both players played like
maybe you know on already
increment like shorter time than like
you know more than
uh i mean less than let's say two
minutes i guess i
i don't know but i guess they didn't
have
much time so for the defensive side
before the scientist is defending it's
especially difficult to play such
positions
and right now uh krishna playing with
queen c3 which is a huge mistake
and to understand why we'll i'll show in
a moment why it's a mistake but the best
move was queen a3
and the point is that queen a3 allows
all sort of contract the counter play
with queen a7
so right now uh if the queen knight six
simply queen a7 follows
and you know bunch of checks follow and
it's not easy to make progress and
but the main idea is that after knight
d3 because this seems like
the critical let's say idea for black to
you know bring this knight forward
white simply holds tactically with queen
a7 after
king f6 queen f7 and knight g5 fork
with withdrawn and game pretty much
still maybe some practical chances
because it's past deep one but like
objectively of course it's just a draw
um so yeah queen a3 would basically
yeah even if 96 then queen e7 we sort of
play this position which is slightly
better for black
with correct play you know white and can
hold but
you know black can definitely try many
many
things here so uh in this position
quincy why what's the big difference
right why is it such a way why
why do i say that quincy is such a big
mistake
well because of with queen b1 that was
available magnus didn't play it though
queen b1 would have given minus huge
i think chances to win the game like
very very quickly he won
anyway but like it would basically give
him a huge chance right now
because if king g2 you know what could
be more logical than kg2
uh now queen d3 and the point is
okay ashes of king h let's say king h2
then queen d3 and queen e1 queen e4
and after greece if we we actually very
similar position as earlier
but now there is queen but the
difference is that king is not
on uh you know as it was
on g1 right uh and it was on g1
just let me double check uh yeah it was
on g1
uh the queen is right now
you see he's on h2 between these two
positions
so as the king is on h2 suddenly there
is queen into queen e2 possible
and if king g2 of course there is some
nice tactics available the same one
as you know queen f7 idea earlier and if
queen e3
we trade queens and this is exactly what
black one is suddenly king is six and
king d5 should
slowly win the game because black skin
is simply much more active
and there's also extra pawn which should
be more than sufficient to win for
for black right now all right
so uh there are also other
while showing why queen belongs so much
better than
let's say 96 what magnus played but um
let's let's see what happened the game
because there are still many things that
happened
queen e3 right now is back let's say
that white is back in back
in business king e8 uh trying to avoid
any checks which is correct
uh now g5 of course 94 would run into
queen the queen a4 which
you know loses the p so 1994 is
impossible
g5 is very logical trying to you know
create you know some weaknesses and
tactically
uh you know winston material maybe
king g1 g4 knight g5 is all logical and
now we enter the queen end game
which is with correct play drawn but
there is
one particular moment which is this
moment
where magnu where harry krishna made a
huge mistake he played
the most natural move right now that
human could possibly play
queen g8 pawn on dj5 is hanging defended
right seemingly is very logical however
this simply loses on the spot
what was important to understand such
positions what i'm trying to say is
activity is the by far the most
important the queen active queen
is the key to you know holding this
position as white
after queen g8 the queen's extremely
passive super passive it's like
doesn't have any even one check the only
purpose of this move is just to defend
g5 pawn
instead what could have played let's say
queen c8 and the point is of queen g5
there is no real
reason to worry about it because queen
c7 can you see it
white simply has a perpetual check the
queen is so active that there is no way
to escape this perpetual check
king d4 queen a4 and like the the czechs
the queen harasses the king you know all
the way around the board and
there is pretty much no way to escape
both checks so
as i say activity is more important than
you know just defenses gpology five
point which is pretty much irrelevant
apart from it being there on the board
uh
so yeah queen ga was a huge mistake
right now uh both
h4 for instance and d5 and also d5 here
are winning
h4 is particularly instructive because
after takes queen d5
all this pretty much force king h2 and
now g3 and black simply wins the spawn
and right now because such of because of
such passive queen on g8
uh white simply you know cannot hope
for uh you know to save this g5 point
because anyway at some point it will
fall
uh or if it will not fall it will keep
this queen
very very passive so let's say queen f4
and queen e5 would be next moves
if g6 always we can play queen f6 the
game is pretty much over right now
uh this is in this end game so but
magnus didn't do it he played queen e4
of course
they had to play on like increment and
understandable that both
players were make mistakes make mistakes
on
playing on increment and after queen six
now quincy it back now we are now now we
are talking
basically queen on c8 is finally you
know in the game and tries to you know
if queen g5 of course would be queen
seven same idea of
perpetual check magnus play queen b1
king h2
queen b6 trying to attack the spawn king
g2 correct queen c5 improving the queen
slightly
and again queen b8 keep the queen active
as
active as it can if d5 queen e5 this was
this had to be played because if queen
b8 queen g5 again question 7 would be
just a draw
uh same perpetual so we need to keep the
queen act as active as
only this possible because harry krishna
played queen g8
and again same mistake right now queen
d5 and same ideas with h4 follow
don't want to show them because okay
i'll just show them quickly
same thing happens essentially so uh
therefore
you know queen act queen's activity is
the key in such
queen and games in general pieces
activity but like especially queens like
if you're
queen's passing like on g8 the game will
be pretty much over very soon
you have to keep your queen active queen
v8 but anyway
quinje happened and magnus bo i mean
both players play on increment for sure
there were lots of mistakes happening
because of
simply because of the little time that
they both had both of them had
but okay queen f5 magnus played which
was a mistake
uh queen b8 finally queen is back to the
game queen e4
d5 and uh right now i think
uh if i remember correctly
there was a mistake by uh hari krishna
who played queen c7
which is again seemingly the most
natural move okay
is not a mistake yet there were also
other moves like queen b6 queen b2 were
also are good the queen is also fine
king avail quindia is all logical
bring the queen forward queen keep
checking
bring the king queen to f6 we can see
right now that white uh white queen is
really active like hurricane f7 pawn
uh does some does a lot right there's
lots of counterplay
so queen g6 makes sense and uh right now
again what was supposed to be the best
defensive idea right now
is to keep simply keep the queen active
queen d8
and you know if the queen let's say
comes to e6 we can play maybe
uh sorry queen come to s25 then queen e7
d4 queen d6 you know keep the queen
active
if the you know the opponent will not be
able to move forward
without the support of the queen and
without support the
uh because of the and if the queen
supports this pawn there will be some
perpetual check that's the basically the
the
the thinking here if queen is six simply
king h2
and again just queen f6 they always will
be if the queen supports the spawn there
there'll always be some perpetual
check ideas also queen seven was
accomplishing the similar stuff in the
sea after queen said queen six queen f8
after d4 just queen d8 you know again
keep the queen as active as
possible in the game it could have
happened queen f4
which is also okay but after queen e6
uh there's only actually one move that
saves the game
or keeps the balance queen c7 queen c7
essentially again activate the queen if
the queen is active
there will be likely chances to make a
draw if the queen is passive
and after uh queen d4 happened in the
game queen queens actually is passive
after king g6 but pawn on g5 simply
falls
and the game is just decided so there is
a nice technique by magnus but just
wanted to show quickly what happened
what uh why queen seven is important
because after king g6 right now queen d8
uh pawn g5 is defended and i just queen
g8 always at least
there's pretty i don't see any way to
make progress here for uh
for black anyway the game happened queen
d4 and the rest is pretty much
straightforward technique by magnus king
g5
you can get five two extra pawns we
don't have to even worry about the h5
pawn because the
again pieces activity is way more
important and king goes forward
uh king simply showed is being will be
sheltered by
our opponent by our d pawn uh and by the
queen
and finally queen c4 that's how the game
ended but anyway position was already
lost here
uh podi pawn would simply go forward the
queen
so this is how the game ended uh with
queen c4 here
so um
i think both both end games were very
interesting uh
despite some mistakes that happened
there
uh mostly due to you know the nature of
the
of the time control and so on uh despite
that there were lots of you know high
quality
games and uh i think
you know there's lots of to learn from
them most importantly let's say
from the from from this one at least the
queen activity and such and games is way
more important just defines g5 point for
instance which is pretty much irrelevant
and yeah that's all i have
for for today thank you guys and i hope
it was interesting
and take care see you next time
[Music]
you